did you always tell stories with your
eyes code do you always tell stories
with your eyes closed thinking but I'm
gonna switch that up thinking about that
right now if you were talking I read the
comments on your videos and so because
these highs look down that's no shame in
mine I don't lie about me in high that
is that's known all my family members
everybody knows I get high I tell
everybody I mean Mexican gang members in
heroin they go together right oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a common thing
yeah the cookies in milk you know Jimmy
hmm but the closed eyes is about what
it's just the way you concentrate those
nose eyes yeah more less close I see
because what I'm speaking on here I want
to speak the actual truth because I
don't want no one to get on that thing
and say oh you're a lying [ __ ]
because I was with you that day and you
know or you need you're lying you know
that's why I told my family they were
like yeah you know everything you're
talking about is true you know what we
do it woulda got me about was the
coconuts because I never told him that
we used to hide open some my grandma's
coconuts on top of TV I never told him
so my aunt's were like that's what that
she would smell it and you know we
couldn't find out what realize that
that's what was that at all times
we already might you ready relax about
the middle of March home art it's pretty
hot you know but today I was gonna talk
a little bit about I'm growing up in the
hood and having family members that are
from my hood and there are family
members from another hood that were
actually enemies and how we go how I go
about him and work it out you know I got
I got like four cousins
throughout of Norwalk no matter one side
of Norwalk cuz I got cousins from oh I
don't know walk and then I got cousins
from people I don't know like and it's
two different neighborhoods but I got
cousins from there you know when I grew
up with them you know it's my mom's
sisters sons you know there's like for
them you know and two of them they're
there they're kind of the main guys from
that hood but you know as growing up
through the years you know I remember
when I was younger and I used to go
visit my grandma's house you know my
mom's mother and I used to go over there
and there were my cousin's with their
homeboys you know I mean and we were
already enemies our hoods didn't get
along we had been already at it for
years and years but I used to go to my
grandma's house and you know if you step
into your grandma's house you know these
beans used to try to tell me that that
was their hood and I used to tell him
look beyond this front yard
his backyard or beyond this front door
of my grandmother's house yeah that's
usually but when you step in my
grandmother's house and you go to the
backyard that no longer is your hood it
may be in your hood but yet that's my
grandmother's house so really that's my
hood you know so you know one time were
down there we were visiting and um Mike
one of my cousin's home boys came he's
an older dude you know he's been around
I heard about him through the years you
know he was from that hood and he was
one of the main characters out of there
but uh this dude he just kept talking
and talking and talking and he was a lot
older you know and I was always taught
by my older homies and my family members
to always respect your elders you know
always excuse me you know I mean pardon
me you know I mean I always you know
helped a lady across the street you know
all the good things things that make
make you up make you you know a
gentleman so I'm always you know calm
and collected most of the time and this
dude's going at it and he's going and
he's disrespecting my homies he's
talking bad about my uncle's you know
meaning this dude just going on and on
and on so I tell him well you know what
I tell him look you're a little bit
older I said and uh you know why don't
you bring your little homies that are my
age you know and you go ahead and line
him up so me thinking that I told you
this that he wasn't gonna do it but
there he goes he left you know what I
mean we're kicking back at my
grandmother's backyard we're getting
drunk as [ __ ] you know we're partying
with my cousins from that hood and here
comes two carloads they get off the car
and there must be about whoo man there
must be about eight or nine youngsters
that are my size I mean I'm they're my
little brother's there it's just me and
my little brother you know the rest dude
they're from Norwalk eNOS so meet my
little brother there so he brings the
guys up and they're all standing right
there and I tell him well you know I
told you to line him up you know so
who's first well I guess when he had
went to go get these guys they had
picked this dude because he was supposed
to be going for his Golden Gloves and
you know he had been boxing for like
four or five years you know and at first
we need when I see him and I heard his
name already I did my homework on this
dude because I had tried to get his
sister previous and she don't want
nothing to do with me because her
brother was my enemy so she didn't want
to get caught up so I kind of knew who
this guy was well they brought him to
you know the middle of the yard you know
I mean and though
he's watching he got all these little
homies right there you know it's me and
my little brother but like I said that's
my grandmother's house so my cousins
that are there they're my cousins they
left at home he's jumped me but he
they're gonna let us go ahead up so I
end up going head up with this dude and
I'll be honest I had to whooping his ass
you know he might be hearing this story
right now and he knows exactly who it is
so you know I'm not running no [ __ ]
but I end up whooping his ass you know I
know I remember whooping his ass and I'm
on top of him that older dude comes and
he [ __ ] snatches me off of him and he
glows me to the side and I tell him I
told you man bring your homies and line
him up well what happened was since I
beat up this first guy I didn't know
that this first guy was had more balls
or had more courage or whatever or was a
better [ __ ] than the rest of his
homies this was like the main dude I
guess they expected him to what my ass
and just get it over with but when the
table's turned the older dude started
telling his little homies amen
get in there none of them wanted to step
in none of them wanted to step in you
know I'm talking about step in the
little circle we made with the benches
and [ __ ] in my grandma's backyard none
of them wanted to step in so now there's
older dudes getting mad and he starts
[ __ ] slapping his little homies you
know he's slapping his little homies and
I'm like what the [ __ ] man you know I
mean why are you slapping these foods
you know I go just because they do you
don't want to fight it man you know you
ain't in your fighting I mean you walk
with a name or an older mommy we're not
disrespecting you I said what if you
want I'll go get my little homies and
bring them down here and you can [ __ ]
fight with them you know I mean I said I
sure the [ __ ] ain't gonna try to slap my
homies around just because they don't
want to get in and fight with an
individual later want to fight with I
said I'm not saying they're scared or
you know they don't got the balls I'm
just saying bottom line they've seen
their homies ass get whooped
maybe he whooped all their asses and
they just don't want the same ass
whooping I gave him well this dude gets
hot he gets mad and he starts talking
about he's gonna go get this and he's
gonna get this out of his trunk and they
said of his trunk so now inside my head
I'm saying you know what this dude went
too far now you know he went too far cuz
now he's talking about hurting people
they'll coming back and lighting up the
whole house and I'm like I'm looking at
my cousin that's from that hood and I'm
like Luke you hear your homey would be
the same right same he's gonna come back
and like the house look you know this is
our grandmother's house you know you're
gonna check your homie or
am I gonna have to call my own ease well
my cousin let it go too long so I ended
up getting on the phone and calling my
homies it was a trick cuz my homies got
there within 10 minutes two carloads
they got there
I remember my homie gets off the car and
gets off the car with without with a 22
rifle and he gots like 38 rounds in her
stomach got the banana clip and I
remember we get on the back fence and my
homies went to go look for these games
so my homies cruised around here comes
my homie in his car he parks it he gets
off he runs in the yard here comes the
two carloads and I remember them coming
by and they were gonna stop but what
happened with my homie just started
letting off on him and I remember when
he was letting off on him I could see
sparks hitting the top of the car on the
side of the car you know sparks flying
off the cars everywhere you know and
they were hitting him you know sparking
off the car sparking off the car and you
know I remember I was laughing because
my homie just stayed lady and I'm having
and I can hear the girls screaming and
the fools yelling inside the cars and I
could see the bullets ricocheting off
and [ __ ] and it was really late at night
it might have been about 3:00 in the
morning you know I mean and you know I
tell that story because of the fact that
you know I was about 13 years old that
older dude was about 28 29 you know and
you know I told him to go get his homies
he went and got them you know I beat the
first one up so the next row of them
didn't want to fight you know mean but
it security because after that happened
you know I kind of started talking to a
few of the guys from that hood because
like I said my cousins were from that
hood and you know uh I used to go in
there but I used to use a different name
you know when I went in Norwalk I used a
different name you know in different
cities I used to use different names
because certain fools knew me by a
certain name and if I was stuck in this
hood and they knew exactly who I was I
don't think I would make it out of there
you know I used to go in in Norwalk you
know and I got like man like 15 cousins
from Norwalk all older dudes you know
been around you know the main cats there
and stuffing I used to go in there and I
used to go in there under a different
name you know and I remember there was a
couple of times a couple of fools see me
that I was in juvenile hall where I
wasn't you
I can't wait and I thought they were
gonna pull my covers you know I thought
they were gonna tell you dudes nah man
this ain't something so big and give him
my real name
if you would've gave him my real name I
think they would have did me dirty I
think they would have really they would
have got rid of me because of the fact
that you know we were going at it with
them as well but now I was going to my
aunt's house and I feel when you step in
somebody's house you know and whether
it's your in-laws or whether it's your
instant family you know all the gang
banging stops but there's a lot of dudes
that they don't take that and use that
they more or less take advantage of that
you know I mean I mean I've went to my
grandmother's house where my cousin had
like ten of his homies there and they're
just looking at us like they want to
just tear us apart but being being that
these are my cousins that's my grandma's
house you know there was no way that I
was gonna let these fools make me leave
or tell me that I could be there or
anything like that because I told them
time and time again beyond this doorstep
that's your hood but in here no this is
my hood this is my grandmother's house
you don't mean and all their [ __ ] down
in there is that anyone mean well that
was that you know I mean that was that
with them you know they're from one gang
so when I go to another gang go to the
big run or walk and these dudes man my
cousin is like I said they're like 15 of
them they're young older you know I mean
and I used to go in there I remember I
just sit down and there must have been
30 40 dudes from that hood right there
you know and they're all looking at me
you know I mean and I aren't you dudes
myself as someone else cuz I told my
cousin's if they hear my name man my ass
is grass you know so cuz I was at was
messin with some other homegirls and I
was coming in their hood kickin it with
their homies but I used to go in there
you know and I used to go to my aunt all
the time and I'm gonna sit with my aunt
and I would see these [ __ ] dudes
crossing the window and they'd be
looking at me like you know like they
wanted to get in you know in Miami get
the [ __ ] away from the window you know
and I'd be laughing because you know I
knew they weren't gonna do anything they
were gonna huffing puff out there and
they were gonna talk to [ __ ] but when it
came down to it I knew that my cousin's
Wang you know
they're homies to do anything to me and
my little brother except maybe go
one-on-one and fight with them and I
used to love to fight you know that was
my thing I was taught you know when I
was a youngster that you know the way my
father used to tell me that they used to
do it and said he was an older guy he
was from my hood he was martyred homey
he said that they used to get in you
know one group right here and one group
right here and they used to get the
toughest fool out of each group and let
them go ahead up and that would be side
everything you know there wasn't no
Rumble there wasn't no jumping this for
jumping that fool so as I grew up you
know I could actually sit here and tell
you I've never jumped anybody I've never
jumped anybody with someone else or I've
never been jumped myself and a lot of
people say oh come on you've been
jumping no I've never been jumped all
the years that I was little right in
being a troll or gang banging all the
years that I was doing that I never ever
got jumped I got close to getting jumped
but I guess because I gave so many dudes
the opportunity and these fools that are
watching this know that if you know me
personally and you're my enemy
I'd always give you the opportunity to
come from the shoulders always you know
always and and if you didn't want it
like that well then we could get
back-to-back take ten paces and turn
around shoot each other it didn't matter
to me the thing about it was is that it
was pushing me so much by my father and
my uncles that they wanted us to earn
our name with these not with this you
know and when I was younger growing up
it wasn't about a drive-by it wasn't
nothing like that it was all about you
know just mainly fights I mean right
after school you know mean or you know
uh at lunchtime you know I mean and I
remember this one time we go to this
arcade they had and you know wish to go
deep over there maybe like 30 40 of us
and then I went to watch a fight you
know I watched these I watched one of my
partners get down with some other guy
and I remember as they're fighting I'm
rooting for my homie and this dude next
to me is rooting for the other dude and
this guy next to me ends up out with me
you know because you know we're trying
to make room for them to fight and hands
up al-rumi so I turn around as soon as I
tell him like what's up [ __ ]
the whole crowd just you know I mean
we're stuck in the middle you know I
this dude's kind of
you know he's kind of big but I know I'm
gonna hurt him so one thing leads to
another I end up busting this whole snot
blob he's bleeding everywhere you know I
mean they're talking about coffee I mean
this dude I didn't even break his nose
it's just busted his snot box you know I
mean uh I wanna start kid after you know
yeah I felt like I was on top of the
world you know but I remember that once
I beat this dude up I went to my
grandmother's house the following week
and who's sitting at my cousin's in my
cousin's room the same dude I beat up
now he's for my cousin's hood and I got
out of my ass time I said you know what
why are you from this hood now you know
is it because we got down last week and
I beat you up you know why do you got to
be from the hood you know I mean this
dude was running around with us but then
a lot of the guys did that they ran
around with us and then they got into
different hoods and the reason I bring
it up is because you know on my father's
side it's like everybody's from my
neighborhood all my cousins my brothers
my sister everybody I mean I wish you
would see a photo you know man I might
just have to bring on the next time and
show you a photo of how deep my family
members are and how many of them are
from my neighborhood you know there's at
least I could say 25 of us I'm talking
about women men of all ages there's like
three or four generations you know
so most of stuff I talk about I talk
about me and my family members the [ __ ]
we do because we did so much [ __ ]
there's so many O's that you know
someone's gonna come along and call my
bluff if I'm up here bullshitting about
anything in general you know but I just
like to talk about you know me myself
and things I've experienced you know
when I was younger you know I've been in
so many situations where you know a
couple of times I've been in a hood
where I'm doing business you know and I
get caught I get caught they catch me
you know I mean they got guns and
everything and they want to [ __ ] get
at my ass and all I do is tell them hey
man go to the third number on my phone
and dial you know me that's all I'm
gonna say you know me because they're
there and they're there to take all my
[ __ ] and I tell them go ahead take it
take it ain't mine so [ __ ] it take it
you know I mean once you telling that
then they start asking themselves you
know what's going on in I can't get too
much information and I never do but I
just let them know if you want call that
third number you know I mean you guys
are know what time it is because time
and time again I've heard you know I'm
over here doing [ __ ] you know I mean I'm
doing [ __ ] in the right way in the right
fashion but you always have that hater
in the background that wants to say
you're making more than you're actually
making like they want to get you living
amongst your means that's the word
that's the wording they use the
terminology living beyond your means
that's what it is
it's called living beyond your means
it's like a [ __ ] got some BMW
2020 parked at a [ __ ] Shack right
there in Compton in the [ __ ] hood
[ __ ] $107,000 car he got it parked in
front of a [ __ ] little rat Shack you
know meaning that his mom is in you know
that's the type of [ __ ] that's
living beyond his means you mean I was
always one that I just wanted to live
comfortable I just wanted to stay high
have enough to share have enough to make
money and also have enough to touch the
ones that really don't have anything
maybe the winos over there the bums you
know I'm always giving dollars up I'm
always giving dope up you know that
that's just me you know but a lot of
times you have those people that that
want to go around and talk about your
business you know I mean and when I used
to go to different cities and my
cousin's lived out there I used to go to
my family's house and doing my all my
business there but the you would always
have these guys man that would be
talking about your business left and
right
tell me women you don't mean telling
their older homies and they'd make it
bigger than it would actually was you
know I'd be selling maybe dimes and
these fools would swear that I'm moving
pounds in their hood you know and it's
like you know it's so [ __ ] up because
you know half these dudes that we're
talking about me I'm taking care of them
you know and if I'm not taking care of
them direct I'm taking care of them
through their homegirl you know because
mainly I was dealing with women because
women they deal dope a little bit
different than men do you know I mean
we're on it and we want it now and we in
here and [ __ ] but now women are more
finessing you know they're more more
wait for the money a little bit longer
you know they got patience you know and
I mean I've dealt with my homegirls were
I mean they made so much money that I
could
believe how fast they would move the
[ __ ] you know I mean and the reason they
were moving it number one because it was
good number two cuz they were gonna get
told anything but then again you always
got that same [ __ ] that wants to
come around try to mix my homegirl up
you know I mean put [ __ ] in her head you
knew me and then my homegirl gonna do
something stupid and then I got exiled
her ass and you know I've exhaled a lot
of my own growth and what I mean by
exile is exile you no longer come around
you don't come to that you don't call
the hood you don't cruise through the
hood
you don't walk through it this is no
longer your hood you know and that has
to be something very very critical like
um for instance I acquire something and
I wrap it up and put it away and never
touch it but yet she comes and grabs it
and puts it somewhere else thinking
she's doing me a favor but the [ __ ]
actually [ __ ] up three months of me
setting something up it took her three
minutes to just [ __ ] that all off why
because she put her hand on it
why because nobody's hands were supposed
to be on it and you even ones that know
what time it is you know what I'm
talking about you know and that's the
type of individual I was when I said
something not I would set it up like the
two week advance you know when I would
make sure everything all my ducks were
in a row you know ever nobody was
touching anything nobody was knowing
anything they would talk about it when
it was done you know I mean and also
used to have to be careful because I
used to go to some hoods and like I said
I got a lot of family members from there
I didn't want to hurt the wrong
individual so sometimes I would call and
come you know ask around who's around
there you know I mean and a lot of times
you meet my cousin's you know I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you that I
haven't shot at my cousin's yeah shut up
my cousin several times would work shot
at my cousin's one time was inside my
own home in front of my grandmother you
know I shot a shot at my cousin because
you know he was totally disrespecting
inside our home yeah we may be enemies
on the streets but now you're inside our
home you're a family member so you need
to act like one we wasn't acting like
that he was disrespecting me
disrespecting my little brother my
grandmother told me to be quiet he got
loud with her his mom my aunt told to be
quiet he got loud
once he got out with her he got out with
my grandma I took my grandma boom I'll
be back as soon as I step down my
grandmother told him she better leave
because she knew where I was going I was
going to my spot I was gonna get my
weapon and I was gonna put a hole in
this little [ __ ] for disrespecting my
grandmother's house you know and no one
does it and no one was allowed to
disrespect that house you couldn't shoot
at that house you can gang bang on that
house you were allowed to do nothing
with that house but because he's my
cousin and he feels he got to like that
he wants to disrespect you know I mean
call him a [ __ ] Pollock you tell me I
ain't [ __ ] you know I mean it why
because his homegirl I'm being winner
and he's jealous because he wants to be
with her you know a lot of times that
happened you know I end up going to hood
meet this finance brought in I'm not
knowing that this is the remain homegirl
like this is their pride and joy you
know all their homeworks look up to this
[ __ ] like cuz she's so fine
you know they put her on a pedestal I
end up being with her and then now the
[ __ ] is like nothing you know I mean a
lot of times I would tell him I'm sorry
you know I didn't know that this was
gonna take place but that's the way your
homeboys are you know I mean they want
to act like they love you and they
cherish you but now you're tainted why
because you're with me
what the [ __ ] are they doing in their
spare time you know meaning I used to
catch a lot of foods from different
hoods in my neighborhood being with my
homegirls if they were being on my
homegirls I would have put him out there
I wouldn't go get my homeys and come and
[ __ ] him up not because then I'm
disrespecting my homegirl maybe she
likes this guy you know I mean and yeah
he's my enemy but that's on her when it
comes down to it and they had pull her
[ __ ] card she's gonna have to answer
for her [ __ ] with this dude so really
I slept that goal you know a lot of [ __ ]
in my hood I let go I used to catch
fools in there from different hoods and
I just let him go and I said Tom go
ahead man walk - I can't speak for the
dudes on the next block that they're not
gonna [ __ ] you up
but me I'm not gonna go out of my way
and [ __ ] you because first of all you're
just walking through here I know you
want to go all the way around I see it
but there's some of your homies that nah
I ain't gonna let them walk through here
they have no business walking through
here because there's a Main Street on
that side and there's a Main Street on
that side your old lady might live down
this way but you can go [ __ ] around
cuz if you go if you go by my house and
you cruise by and you're looking I'm
gonna look at you if you bust a u-turn
I'm gonna send my kids in send the dog
in I'm
get my [ __ ] come out you go by again I'm
gonna give you one more look if you
[ __ ] make another u-turn
imma [ __ ] light you up when you come
by the third time because the first time
you came by I'm figuring you're just
checking out who's around you know I
mean to see who you can get with me if
you got personal [ __ ] one of my homies
but then when you're busted you turn oh
man now you're looking for trouble
you're looking for trouble
but now if you turn back a third time
you lookin to hurt somebody so I'm hurt
you first and many times that has
happened you know when I shot at my
cousin I shot at him out my bedroom
window I shot at him in his mom's car I
his mom's car like two times my aunt got
upset you know when she yelled and
everything you know she wanted my
grandmother to [ __ ] whoop my ass and
everything but my grandmother stream
where I was coming from you know and I
was her favorite but at the same time he
just didn't disrespect me and he
disrespected his mother my grandmother
his aunt he disrespected the whole
family you know he disrespected my home
and at that time you know I might have
been 16 years old but I was the one
taking care of business for my family
you know I mean I was the one that came
to when there was a problem
I wasn't want to go deal with that I
also wanted to go take care of it you
know me and to be honest with you the
[ __ ] got old you know I mean you got old
after a while I was asking myself you
know why are they laying all the
problems on my hands as you know I got
seven cousins seven uncles and they're
just as [ __ ] tough man they're just
as [ __ ] bad man they've been to
prison more times than me but yet when
someone wants to come talk to somebody
they want to call me bring me from my
home bringing out what I'm doing so I
can go talk come and talk to somebody
when we're in our reality
they can talk to him just as well you
know I mean but they always want to put
me there so I do the talking then that
ties me in the next thing I know I'm in
my hood again I'm got the [ __ ] keys
and I'm [ __ ] hating life I'm hating
life because I cannot move I'm obligated
by something to stay there and make sure
everything goes good and because of the
obligation I'm [ __ ] you know I mean I
can't go to spend time on my
girl I can't go spend time with my wife
you know I mean I'm right here posted up
24 hours a day you know me making sure
everything is going according to plan
you know and I used to trip because I
get my homies and we'll have our little
meetings and [ __ ] and I remember when I
used to say okay well here this is your
street in your spot and then my homie
over here would get upset why are you
giving it to him you know and I used to
get that all the time and that's telling
me look the way it looks right now is
everybody smoking dope [ __ ] are
coming to the writing on the walls you
know up in the pad I mean when I was
busted there was fools my enemies up in
my house being with my cousin's and they
were in my house where I grew up at and
I was really upset about that you know
meaning when I got it I told my homies I
can't believe that these fools were up
in this house it's like the main house
in the hood and we got our enemies
laying up in here all night even if I
was in prison you [ __ ] [ __ ] came
and removed these fools out of here you
know I mean they were actually in here I
felt kind of sick from my stomach when I
walked in my house when I got out of
prison I walked in the house I thought
kind of 6-10 me because I was imagining
that these [ __ ] were up in here
just kicking in another refrigerator
laying on the sofa like it was their
spot I could just imagine what they were
saying to their homeys when they went
back oh yeah we're in this house the
last name and all that [ __ ] in used to
make me real upset matter of fact even
one of my cousin's had a baby from one
of the foods he used to go to my house
you know and I seen him after I got with
his program I heard him pretty bad but
you know the reason I heard him so bad
was because he was the one that used to
go to the house and just disrespect you
know cuz we were all busted all the
younger boys from from my family were
all busted we're all in prison you know
one was in white but the rest were in
prison all my uncles were older they
were living their lives so really no one
was out there was just a lot of the
cousins they're all girls and you know
they had all [ __ ] kinds of foods from
everywhere coming in visiting you know
I'd be in prison and a food be like hey
I've been in this house right here in
this spot and I'd be like okay you've
been there tell me what's on the walls
in the living room and you got to tell
me exactly what's there because if they
don't tell me what's in the bedroom
they never been to my house I've caught
many [ __ ] in Liars and I asked
him what's in the living
there was only three things in the
living room was on one of the walls it
was in Aztec calendar on the other side
of the wall there was a clock an o clock
and in the middle side of the wall it
was a portrait of my uncle black Bob he
was a portrait of him in the bunch of
via dates the Civil War games you know
with being wiped pearl-handled gun with
cross stop bullets with the sombrero hat
back you know big old monster as long as
hair you know it was a portrait of him
and I says dude you know what's on the
walls in there you know and like I said
the walls are just blank it's just the
picture of him they iced a calendar and
a clock you know and when freeze you
tell me oh there's some pictures of
you're [ __ ] lying bro you're lying
you're lying but now if I dude told me
oh well there's a picture of your own
corner okay boom you've been there you
know I mean and a lot of foods used to
try to like you know take the credit any
things to go to my house because they
were related to the family but I tripped
up because I even had cousins that
wouldn't come over you know and I would
call him and tell him hey man you know
when you come over my only thing in a
trip you know you're my cousin [ __ ] what
they're thinking now I'm gonna go there
I already know how you guys are it
wasn't even like that but a lot of times
you know I would go there to their house
and I knew exactly what they would feel
because you know maybe their homies one
saying [ __ ]
but in the back there staring at me you
know I mean you know me [ __ ] like that
and I'm like yeah yeah you ain't gonna
do [ __ ] but it was just you know being
from my hood having so many family
members from the hood and then having a
lot of family members from other hoods
made it real difficult as I was growing
up you know I mean because this is my
family you know I mean and a lot of
times they'll be with their home using
like I show up at my grandma's house and
there's like tenant in there you know
they want my ass you know I mean even
though my cousin's would step up and be
like hey man [ __ ] that you ain't gonna
do nothing to my cousin's they want my
ass for other reasons they don't want my
ass just because they want my ass they
won't last because the last weekend when
I came to the hood and get the rats up
or I said that homeboy or I beat their
home you up they want my ass behind that
a lot of times they wanted mass because
like I said
I was messing with their main homegirl
and I didn't know that she was like a
prized possession of them like she was
like top notch [ __ ] I didn't know that
you know I mean one time I even got
caught on a swing with one of their main
hungers from East LA somewhere and all
her homies caught us all I had was a
blanket around me naked with her by
negatron a swing inside a little [ __ ]
like playground and these [ __ ]
surround me I had a 357 it right tucked
away but they caught me in the way they
were looking at me was like like I don't
they expected me to take the blanket off
and let them see their home girl naked
or what but I'm telling her like [ __ ]
what do we do what he do you know
because she's telling me just warning
she's telling at home boy leave man
leave he's upset because he's all in
love with her I didn't know this if I
would have known this from jump I would
have never touched a broad because
[ __ ] are serious about their
homegirls serious about their girls you
know me a [ __ ] would kill you
over a [ __ ] and that's one thing I
never wanted you know I mean but I
always to put it back on their home girl
you know I said yeah you told me that
your homie liked you but you didn't tell
me that you're with him before and that
you're still leading him on cuz a lot of
times women would do that you know women
would leave the [ __ ] home way on and
then go be with another fool from
another hood they would end up getting
into it kill one another behind her so I
didn't want to be a statistic you know
I'm saying most of all I didn't want to
hurt one of my cousins you know cuz i
also had girl cousins that were older
had him that was younger had girl
cousins that sold dope you know man
remember I went to this house one time
and I knocked on the door to buy some
drugs and when the door open the lady
looked at me and she said you look
familiar you know what's your name I
told her my name don't behold I didn't
know that this was my cousin you know I
mean I was going in her house you know
me and then I'm over buying some drugs
that she knows I ain't using so she said
we want these drugs for and I'm like
brother from the older homie you know
and she's like well I don't even want to
put it in your hand I'm like it's not
for me you know it's for them you know I
don't use that [ __ ] and at that time it
was heroin
I was only maybe like 16 and she and I
was going to pick up a whole piece and
she didn't want to put it in my hand and
I was turning to look I gave you the
money already I need to take this back
cuz if I don't take this back it's my
you know she didn't want to she didn't
wanna so funny I called my home and I
told her ma'am and she don't want to
give it to me and then she broke it down
and she gave it to me but being that she
was my cousin you know she didn't want
to get caught up with my grandmother I
had to tell her oh yeah why gave him a
whole piece of heroin you know and I
don't even use the [ __ ] you know I'm
saying that I remember you know they
used to bring it so much dope to the
house or when they used to come knock on
the door like 3:00 in the morning oh my
god leads to come knock on the door
puh-puh-puh buh-buh-buh I'll go dog or a
dog listen boom over here comes my
grandmother she'll get up what the hell
turn the light on she'll go to the door
and show open the door and the person on
the other side of the door would be all
[ __ ] up talking about crab by 20
they're asking my grandmother if they
can buy our 28 dope when they should be
asking me or my cousin or they're asking
my grandmother because there's so high
so now my grandmother knows one of you
[ __ ] is selling drugs she knew that
she couldn't pinpoint who's but she tell
me
I know wanting you [ __ ] are
selling drugs because last night at 3 in
the morning when she wasn't lying
because I heard home girl came to the
door banging on the door for a [ __ ]
20 did you know I mean I grandma was
like what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] hell
out of my house you know I mean it not
be just mainland steel like oh [ __ ] you
know I mean in the morning I tell my
little brother why do you have these
smoked grass [ __ ] coming to the door
two or three in the morning asking
Ramnath selling some [ __ ] dope
because you know all those and homeboys
out there they're always gonna be there
I learned that they're always gonna be
there and I also learned that they do
some stupid ass [ __ ] you know you can
just imagine them going in house can ask
in your grandmother to sell them some
dope you know I said tell my homegirls
how old are you you know you're not a
little kid why would you go to my
grandma's house and knock on the door
and ask her to buy dope I didn't know
who's your grandmother you didn't know
was my grandmother oh no [ __ ] you've
known my grandmother for 30 years on the
[ __ ] you're gonna sit here and line
out now you're gonna line out you ain't
getting [ __ ] so I had to put in my own
girls on restriction they can't buy no
dope they'd be mad for a little bit but
yet they [ __ ] mines off because now
when I wake up in the morning that's the
first thing I'm gonna hear from my
grandmother is horn [ __ ] it selling
drugs out of my house you know I tell
myself assuring her telling my little
brother on my cousin Dan gonna tell on
me but now we're all gonna get lined up
and my grandmother's my grandfather's
gonna get his favorite [ __ ] big ass
dick and whip it across her back because
a [ __ ] home girl came to the house
that's not asking for drugs so we'll all
get whipped in the back with a big-ass
dick and it was like nine of us
sometimes he'd break the stick on one of
us and he'll [ __ ] don't move and
you'll [ __ ] throw the little piece
down and go get the other piece and just
go to town with that you know so many
times he's broke it over one of our
backs he used to hit us with a stick he
used to hit us with the [ __ ] back of
a [ __ ] axe handle um he used to
[ __ ] put his belt around his hand and
suckers dead in the jaw I remember he
stuck me in front of my girlfriend right
in my jaw
he sucked him so hard I seen those
little lights fly around and [ __ ] you
know and I never got hit by my
grandfather really it's just that I
think I was going to school and he was
gonna take me by my girlfriend was there
and she was complaining and I was
arguing with her and then he said
something and I said something wrong to
him
he ended up putting on a glove and
sucked me dead in the jaw right in front
of her you know me and I thought
embarrassed you know my grandmother
stuck me in my mouth in front of my
girlfriend you know now I'm gonna [ __ ]
my girlfriend up you know and I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up you know because she's the
one talking [ __ ] and I'm trying to go to
school you know and you know I I was
getting an education at the same time
being again but I had my grandfather
taking me to school and picking me up
you know I mean and this was knowledge I
was young 15 16 I was in some [ __ ]
school that no one else went to you know
and you know I remember my grandfather
when he I was the only when he beat up
he beat up all my cousins all my uncles
and I seen he beat up everybody for some
reason I was always there and he was the
type of [ __ ] where he'd catch
you by yourself and he tell you don't
move don't move any and you look around
no one's there and he'll just [ __ ]
call back in crack right in the [ __ ]
jaw hard - I seen him [ __ ] pull my
uncle's to sleep he wouldn't hit us as
hard but he'd suck everybody in the John
I seen him suck all my uncle's
my cousin's in the jaw all of them then
he socked me in the jaw nice laugh at
damn Italian but once I got something in
the jaw I was like oh [ __ ] my
grandfather didn't play you know I mean
he was a real honest you know I mean
hard-working man you know I mean and I
remember he used to say I was in the
Army I was an army you know and he was
in World War two you know and he used to
tell us you know I killed for a reason
you guys are killing for no reason you
guys are just out or killing why don't
you go to the service and go kill for a
reason you know and I used to tell him
it's just like the service I see we got
a gun we got army they got an army and
we just go at it needs to tell me yeah
but you do for a reason he said I killed
for a reason you know and yeah a lot of
confirmed kills you know through his
[ __ ] you know he boxed in the service
and all that he was a truck driver
retired so anything he put forward he
had back up you know saying so he used
to tell us to get a job go to work but
on the other side flip side of the coin
my grandmother or let us buy the big
baggy clothes
the Pendleton's the [ __ ] hair nets
you know she would let us dress like a
gangster but my grandfather totally
opposite he wanted us all to be workers
and we were caught up man you know from
generation to generation you know we
didn't have to get jumped in we walk
data in as soon as we turned 13 years
old we're in the hood you know I think
my little brother was like you living
and my youngest cousin was like 10 but
he was like off the hook you know he was
young but they had the brain capability
of thinking like an adult you know these
fools were young but they thought at a
different level you know they they
carried themselves when I seen him
running with the certain guys they were
running with I couldn't believe my eyes
cuz I wouldn't even run with these
[ __ ] the fools they were
running with I wouldn't even run with
them I wouldn't want to run with them
I'd want to be around them I want
nothing to do with them I don't want to
get caught up in it but these fools will
be cruising with them in a car with the
shotgun hanging out the door and I'd be
like damn and I would ask them after how
do you kick it with this dude and feel
comfortable I can't feel comfortable to
kick it with somebody that's actually
someone because of the fact that any
move you doing wrong you're gonna be
held accountable for you know saying and
you know going through the hood and the
I wanted to be the best I could be in my
hood I wanted to be that hood star I
wanted to put in the work I didn't want
to get told nothing by my homies I
wanted to just do what I had to do and
it went like that for a while
it did it did but then you got these
homies that get out of jail and I don't
know how these [ __ ] are they come to
the hood he jumps up his car I pulled
out a gun pointing at him and now I'm on
home he's got me and they're scolding me
because I pulled a gun on my older homie
but yet he jumped out of the car like he
was gonna do something I don't know this
guy he just finished doing 20 years I
was just a kid when he went to jail now
he jumps out of his car and I pull a gun
I don't know I'm in trouble
you know I'm saying it was just like for
my cousin's when they would come a
couple of times we dream down on them
not knowing that there were more cousins
my aunt gets off the car now are in
trouble my grandmother's gonna [ __ ] us
up because we pulled the gun up on our
aunt you know I mean but that's what the
difficult part of growing up when you
have cousins from other hoods and you're
also their enemy you know it was really
hard you know I mean because I'm telling
you you used to come to our house and my
homies are deep and I had homies that
would disrespect my cousins and I'll be
that game what the [ __ ] you doing dog
[ __ ] that [ __ ] say yeah okay
[ __ ] the [ __ ] but catch him at a
different time
right now he's visiting my grandmother
you know it's not a tattoo bang right
now but a lot of homies are hard-headed
in there like [ __ ] that [ __ ] cuz
we're mean enemies we're killing each
other but yet these are my cousins
that's my blood you know they just
happened that they grew up on that side
of town we grew up on this side of town
there are a lot of times I would tell
him you should have been from over here
but then again they're my cousins and in
my head I say well that's the reason
that hood so strong because they got
individuals like him that keep it going
because I'm the type of antigen we'll
individual it keeps Michael going and
everybody has those individuals but the
way we had him was three my cousin's
over here five of them from over here
seven from over here and it's like [ __ ]
what do we do when we meet up and their
homies are tripping our homies are
tripping what's gonna happen and you
know that all through the years all
kinds of [ __ ] took place but we never
ever disrespecting each other except at
one time then I had to shoot I went
cousin at my house because he
disrespected my grandmother and his mom
but you know I wanted to share that with
you today because of the fact that
there's a lot of people out here that
are from the hood and it's only them
imagine being from your hood and there's
like 15 of your family members from the
hood and then there's family members
from other hoods and when you're doing
things you gotta remember everybody's
giving their opinion
everybody's saying what they think
should happen you know I mean I used to
have ladies coming to ask me not to hurt
their son lady I didn't even know you
but this lady knows exactly about me I
find out that she's my aunt's friend
used to work with her over here but her
son's coming through all I would tell
her was tell your son not to ride on the
walls and not to cruise through my hood
and not to beat my homegirls other than
that he's cool what happens in next week
I catch the [ __ ] riding on the
walls why did his mom even come for
that's why I ask myself why did he do
his mom's coming asking me not to do
anything to him and then the next week
they're [ __ ] doing exactly what I
told her mom to tell him not to what
what I don't want him doing you know me
and I remember the mom she's coming I
said tell him even though I'm gonna tell
you right now what I don't want to do it
your boys still gonna do that and they
would say well but we want you to kill
him
whoa you don't want me I don't even know
what you're talking about
and coming from older ladies older
ladies that have jobs that are citizens
you know that don't aim the gang bang
[ __ ] and they couldn't ask me that a lot
of times I would look at them like oh
how can you say something like that how
could even put anything out there like
that where did you hear this about me
you know you had to hear from somebody
because you're telling me not to kill
you boy like what are you talking about
I don't even do that but yet you're
asking me and she's asking me with a
sincere heart
some of them would cry you know some of
them would tell me I tell them time and
time again not to do this but he don't
listen and then I would tell him I heard
they're dead it's your fault because you
let him get into that [ __ ] hood
you're my uncle and you're from the hood
but you let my cousin come from another
hood how does that work they'll be like
my father lady me and my little brothers
[ __ ]
come from our enemy hood and gaming here
it's my own family that's what I didn't
understand cuz I thought my uncles had
sons from my enemy hood and I'd be like
how the [ __ ] does that work you know
we're gonna go break the windows on his
house and find out that it's my aunt's
house after we break the windows and
[ __ ] we get home my grandmother's
whipping the [ __ ] out of us cuz we went
and broke our aunts [ __ ] windows at
her house not knowing that was our
aunt's house not knowing that was our
cousin we ain't seen the [ __ ] in
years old sin he's all banged out doing
her signs he's our enemy we break all
his windows and it's my aunt's house now
she's sitting in the living room my
grandma's [ __ ] this up talking about
you broke all her windows now we gotta
pay for the windows but no one told us
that this was our aunt nobody let us
know all we know is this little [ __ ]
came to the house threw a brick at us we
went back to his house broke all his
windows lo and behold it's my aunt's
house well I want to share that with you
today mark because you know uh each time
I come I like to share something
different this time I just shared having
family members from the hood it ain't
always what it's cracked up to be
you know I mean because they're pooling
from every direction you know and you
get tired of getting pulled in both ways
get tired of people coming and telling
you not to hurt this person or to stay
away from this house retrieved from this
house I felt that if my cousin's get it
coming gangling and he's gonna break my
grandma's windows I'm gonna go break his
grandma's windows even if their sisters
even if it's my aunt's house I'm gonna
break her windows he came in broke my
grandma's windows I'm just giving him
what he gave off she's gonna pay for new
windows she's gonna pay for new windows
you know and I used to do tit for tat
I never went beyond I just you do this
to me I'm gonna do to you let's go back
and forth you know I loved revenge you
know what I loved revenge and I walked
on that you know but that's why I got
free skate mark you know oh cool always
great yes lovely mark lovely
you